the staff of John fetterman say this
will make it easier for them to find
comfortable clothes for his body double
oh good yeah yeah yeah
it's kind of interesting and also so he
gets to wear his shorts and Mitch
McConnell goes back to wearing his shell
what do you think of this
um well you know looking at him I feel
like he looks the way that like all
Senators feel on the inside you know
like he's sort of manifesting it um I
don't know he looks like he'd be like
really cheap to bribe you know I don't
know if there's any lobbyists out there
but it's like if you didn't think you
were Rich enough to be able to you know
affect change like you know just throw
this guy a five yeah and a kegger yeah
we got a keg in the back of this truck
also the truck's yours wow
amazing amazing
cat you know do you do you think it's
important to dress well for the
government because you hate government
does this matter I mean I I don't dress
well no come into work no you don't at
all you saw it you'd be disgusted no
he's right
um because I want to be cold yeah um but
yeah I'm not in the government and I
just he does dress like Adam Sandler and
that's an insult to Adam Sandler
do you think he likes to wear active
wear cats wants to look relatable he
wants to be like I'm just like you but
it's impossible to be in the government
and be just like me because you work for
me yeah yep so you look at that look at
him now and you think is like he doesn't
look relaxed he looks like if you saw
that guy you'd want to call the police
and say I found the guy you're looking
for